good eyebrow eyebrow death good eyebrow
eyebrow that is probably an asshole in
real life hi guys my name is Tamra
chambers and this is Tamra's never seen
and by your request
after watching Young Frankenstein I am
watching Blazing Saddles tonight and
just to clear something up from the Back
to the Future Part three reaction video
that I did I have seen Land Before Time
I've seen more Land Before Time movies
than I care to admit I actually really
loved laying before time that's a great
movie um then it just kept going and
going and going and going but I have not
seen Blazing Saddles and I'm very
excited to watch it so let's find out Oh
Tanner has never seen Oh
oh yeah no nope nope that would not fly
today in a great way
I loved it five minutes into the movie I
had heard every offensive term in
reference to a human being then I think
I've ever heard in my life
and a few new ones too I'm just gonna
say this read beginning right at the top
here um I thought the movie was
incredible because it is obviously
obviously it's incredible um so I don't
want anyone to misinterpret my enjoyment
of the movie for thinking that you
should be allowed to say those things in
all seriousness they were making fun of
it and they did a very good job of it
but just I know that's obvious I
shouldn't have to say that but just
gonna put it out there as like Tamra's
stamp of like
don't say these things seriously Twitter
now that would probably be YouTube right
off the get-go there is incredible
physical comedy that you don't really
see anymore today and it was done well
and is hilarious I'm not gonna say
hilarious in this video I think the
count got up to 15 last time 15 I don't
know I don't remember it's fine you'll
have to go back and look but it got up
really high so the bad guys are trying
to get land from the peaceful people of
Rock Ridge and this movie is so honest I
didn't know that they were making fun of
white people in the 70s I just thought
they were rightfully doing it now
so you see Rock Ridge and there's this
song playing about how peaceful it is
and how what a great small quaint town
it is and then they like rush in and
pillagin I really want to remake that
whole scene with channel awesome people
I think it just would be a blast I just
want an excuse to remake it isn't what
I'm trying to say and then of course in
the church town meeting they're like we
need a new sheriff and then the new
sheriff comes and he's black and they
all flip their shit especially the
disgusting and funny governor who is Mel
Brooks so Bart the new sheriff does the
whole scene where he's speaking in two
different personalities is himself like
it's angry like I'll shoot him I'll
shoot you do anything crazy
it's like don't don't just listen to him
because think it's one of the best one
of the better comedic scenes I've ever
seen with like a solo person doing a
split personality thing super well done
way to go Bart I know that's not its
actual name this is character name cuz I
just looked at them
I didn't know as carretoni I don't
retain people's names in movies you guys
you know this now from seeing all of
these episodes
um I don't retain names and movies I'm
just like oh yeah the kind of the curly
hair
oh the hero of the story she was cool oh
yeah it was a mouse you know and then
you see Gene Wilder's character who from
the second he enters the movie is an
incredible delight he's super toned down
in his movie all of his lines are so
good like barks like you need any help
but he's hanging upside down he's like
all that I can get so then you find out
he's the wake okay at the fastest drawn
world and that scene also wonderful he's
like see this hand is like a straight
hurts
it's sturdy it doesn't shake whatever
he's like yeah but this one is cool I
shoot with so good I smoked a bike with
my hair sorry but but he okay so anyways
he was the Waco kid but he quit because
a six-year-old shot him in the butt
pretty valid reason I feel like the
white humans portrayed in this movie
made me laugh so flipping hard the next
scene is literally just a bunch of white
people around a campfire eating beans
and farting laughs so Mel Brooks was
supposed to cut that scene out of the
movie and he was like yeah for sure I
will and then didn't there's only one
part he was just cut a bunch of scenes
but there's only one part Doug told me
this that he cuts and I will get in this
scene you see Mongo who's this giant man
beast and they decided he should kill
the sheriff and then he punches a horse
so you're like well yep he could
probably kill a sheriff but Bart the
sheriff takes care of him in a
wonderfully stylized way and they decide
to call in the big guns a woman which
let's be real it's very accurate and I
didn't realize she was in this but it's
Madeline Kahn or Madeline Madeline Kahn
from
I'm sure more things in this but y'all
brain Stein who I what I just saw
she is so flippin funny what else has
she been in I could look this up
Google's a thing but I love her I think
she's so funny and everything I've seen
her in which two things I probably seen
her in more things I just don't know it
again I don't retain names anything
pretty colored the next scene is her
seeing this hilariously like flats not
really great um burlesque style song
it's really difficult to sing off-key
when you are a singer and she obviously
is great but everything she does so I
assume she's a singer she's like the og
Miranda sings then she tries to seduce
the sheriff but she just falls in love
with him because he's awesome and she
looks at his whoa
and this is the scene that they cut out
she's like oh is it true what they say
about black men and their bluh bluh it's
like wow take a look baby and she like
unzips to the zipper and she's like oh
it's true it's true it's true that they
cut and I guess from that Doug said they
cut she was supposed to say it's true
and then he's like baby you're sucking
on my elbow or my arm or something like
that
so that guy's make a help-wanted ad for
all evildoers to come and kill the
sheriff and they hold interviews for us
so Jim and Barnes steal some KKK outfits
and go check it out also job interview
for crooks is a really funny sketch idea
remember that so they've got all these
crooks and terrible people coming to
destroy the town and destroy the sheriff
so the entire town joins up with the
railway rail way workers from the
beginning that I didn't talk about it
all but who were hilarious funny they
build an entire like pop-up town set
town in one night so they get almost the
entire town done and the crooks are
coming and this tactic that they use to
slow them down is hilarious the tollway
that they use is just like this giant
like cardboard Tollway thing it fits in
the middle of a
and it's so flippin funny because
they're riding up on horses and there's
like all these horses and there's like
this one little Tollway and they're like
just ten cents does anyone have a dime
in the plug no we gotta go back get all
the dimes so they invade the fake town
and they realize they've been duped and
then Jim is shooting at them from like a
mile away a horse explodes into the air
it's fun they get into a huge fight
which leads them breaking into another
set it's like a soundstage and there's
all of these male dancers doing like a
musical theater number and they all
start fighting then they break out of
that soundstage and they're running
through Hollywood and I was watching the
movie I was like did I miss something
what I thought there is okay all right
no questions being asked don't ask
questions just watch
so then head late the bad guy his name
is Headley never mentioned that you all
know um goes to a theater in Hollywood
to watch the movie blazing simple and
then before he goes in he like goes to
get candy and then the sheriff shows up
and he gets shot
so then Jim and Bart go into the theater
to watch the rest of Blazing Saddles and
that's the end
I think the silliness that they pulled
off in this movie is something that I
feel like a lot of movies now try to
accomplish and like why are you stopping
this at a low low also it's a weird
topic topic topic topping weird topic
talking about the the racism aspect in
this movie with kind of things that we
deal with today um the racism that we
deal with today um and I said this
already but I think it's just so clever
how they did it in such a
tongue-in-cheek way such a obvious like
slapping the face with Doug you dummies
so stupid but while we're on the subject
black lives matter don't dress up like a
Native American for Halloween less
you're a Native American and cats are
awesome but I'm very excited for next
week's adventure I am going to watch
Evil Dead possibly I am watching you've
said 1 2 & 3 also also there are four
Saturdays are there four are there five
there are five Saturdays in October so
I'm doing Evil Dead one two and three
maybe I'll do one of the remakes I don't
know should I maybe but then after that
Hovis I possibly I'm doing something
with mr. Malcolm ray for an episode that
we're going to collaborate on very
excited to work with that lovely
gentleman also if you want hints on what
I'm going to be watching follow me on
Twitter Tamara L chambers because I
usually do a bit of life tweeting during
my first viewings of these movies as
well thank you for the recommendations
to watch Blazing Saddles I really
enjoyed it
you guys are awesome I'm awesome I get
so awesome
[Music]